urlaub mit dem camper ist in diesen
zeiten gerade besonders beliebt denn man
ist frei und unabhängig und tut sich
nicht im hotel mit vielen anderen
menschen
doch kann man sein auto einfach zum
camper umbauen und was muss man beachten
bei dieser art von urlaub darüber
spreche jetzt mit auto bild reporter
alexander fehling hallo alexander kann
man denn jedes auto einfach so zum
camper umbauen
nicht jedes auto aber normal kombi oder
beispielsweise so einen kleinen
kastenwagen wie im citroen berlingo oder
ehepartner oder und vw caddy das
überhaupt kein problem
es muss nur die rücksitzbank umlegbar
sein so dass man eben eine matratze rein
klickt und dann kann es eigentlich auch
schon losgehen
was braucht man alles dafür eine
matratze hast du gerade schon gesagt was
nach und wie viel kostet da sie viel
kosten muss man dann investieren also
was immer gerne vergessen wird ist ein
ganz vernünftiger stuhl denn wenn man so
gegen ballistische unterwegs sein will
man kämpfen dann hält man sich sehr und
deswegen aber es hat dann wie gesagt
matratze beispielsweise so eine
ausbaubare selbst aufblasbaren matratzen
und essen muss man natürlich auch was
das geht zum beispiel so ganz einfach an
info an morgens für den kaffee so ein
kleiner ist nordkorea und ein camping
gestört ich das hier zb das aluminium
das schon ganz günstig so abbau euro
dass da so ein kleiner und kleiner
teekessel drin
[Musik]
dann sei alles ganz praktisch durch das
reich als gläser nämlich beispielsweise
immer hier so einfache stapel kaeser
und das wasser das ist habe ich aus dem
kanister wenn man den füllt dann geht er
so ein bisschen auseinander als zehn
liter und dann kann man den haken ihr
aufhängen
du kannst das ganz gut leben unten
auspacken
dass so ein bisschen komfortabler haben
will dann ist die box ganz gut
das hier ist eine komplettbox liegt
wirklich so gut wie zu hause den schrank
die kostet aber auch so um die 400 euro
und so normale boxen mit so einem
kleinen thermoelement obendrauf die mal
auf den zigarettenanzünder im auto
stecken kann gehen so abgelegt ist 60
euro los ging aber
eine so gute leistung wie so einige ja
und wenn man dann noch ein stück einheit
geben will in sachen komfort dann auch
mit steinen toiletten besteht im prinzip
aus zwei teilen hier oben sitzt man
drauf und hier unten das ist der tank
dann kann man dann irgendwo entleeren
auf dem campingplatz einem stellplatz
da gibt es immer so so einrichtungen und
das talent sorg gehört und im prinzip
das hier jetzt alles zusammenrechnet da
sind natürlich gute sachen weil ich das
schon sehr lange macht ist man bei 800
euro
aber man kann beispielsweise wenn man
schon kombi zu hause hat auch eine ganz
einfache matratze nehmen vielleicht eine
die man zu hause sowieso schon hat da
kann man dann zum abnehmen kann die mit
so einem brotmesser mit wellenschliff zu
schneiden wenn die irgendwie zu lang
sein sollte für den kombi
ja und da kann man halt im prinzip schon
aus dem was man sowieso schon zu hause
hat sich ganz einfach selber bauen und
wo darf man dann mit einem camper hin wo
darf man stehen wenn man dann eingebaut
hat oder eingekauft hat also als oder
minimalistischen aktion würde sich
natürlich schon normaler campingplatz
empfehlen weil der auch die sanitär und
bushäuschen da kann man die toiletten
mit nutzen es gibt aber auch die
möglichkeit auf etwas weniger gut
ausgestattete heißen stellplätze zu
gehen da gibt es dann meistens so sollen
sich strom zapfen kann manchmal auch mit
toilette das findet man zum beispiel bei
camping internetseite da gibt es
stellplatz tipps und es ist natürlich
auch so dass zur wiederherstellung der
fahrtüchtigkeit im prinzip überall eine
nacht über nacht werden darf aber
grundsätzlich ist das natürlich besser
wenn man dann auf einen ausgewiesenen
bereich gibt wo man darauf wetten darf
und welchen führerschein brauche ich für
einen solchen kemper also wenn es ein
normaler lieferwagen isst oder trinkt
oder direkt natürlich der normale
autoführerschein der führerschein klasse
b der geht fahrzeuge bis 3 5 tonnen
zulässiges gesamtgewicht da sind dann
auch schon hier zum release mit drin
also der wiegt sogar 2,8 tonnen maximal
alles was drüber ist also wenn man es
jetzt beispielsweise einen gebrauchten
für einen lkw ausbauen will
auch man so erscheinen klasse c1 oder
eben einen alten führerscheinklasse 3
der dann bis siebeneinhalb tonnen geht
aber im prinzip bei dieser
minimalistischen bei den
minimalistischen ansatz reichte
autoführerschein und kommen aus
dankeschön alexander feininger für diese
wirklich sehr anschauliche schalter
vielen dank